[Music]
[Applause]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
super-pumped to be talking about all
things humanity all things humour all
things touring comedy radio personality
we have Rudy Ortiz joining us on the
show savon oh man
super pumped likewise I'm glad glad you
invited me and I'm glad to be here yeah
yeah and I'm glad that we met like two
issues ago and we just been keeping an
eye on each other and now we're here
we're gonna be talking about how you got
here and what is going on to the state
of humanity and how in comedy really
pumped for those that don't know Rudy's
background he's a touring comedian he is
also a Bay Area radio personality and he
is gonna be talking a lot about these
two things and much more really pumped
so let's start Rudy I like talking about
things on a big history perspective yeah
on civilization so all right we find
ourselves as stewards of Earth after a
long period of evolution and now we're
trying to figure out how to work
together as a bunch of social primates
on this rock orbiting a star so how the
hell how the hell do we do it what's the
current synthesis of humanity well I
mean there are I know there's a lot of
people out there that you know won't
agree with this necessarily but I think
that the cure to humanity has just
always been you know within us and we
just continue to overlook the fact that
what what I think we need to do what
would be best for all of us is you know
peel back a little bit and get back in
touch with the one thing that all humans
have in common and that's you know
compassion trying to be thoughtful for
one another looking out for one another
truly trying to take care of each other
without any incentive or without any
agenda in particular I mean these are
the things that you do with your family
within your home and if you can start if
we can start you know going back to or
maybe not even going back but just
making it a point to try to elevate
ourselves into
a state of mind where we're thinking
about everybody as if they were our
family members and trying to take care
of them that way
then I think we'll be better off I mean
you know technology has taken us to a
place now where I think that we're
actually losing touch with our own
humanity and not even just you know the
way I look at a stranger on the other
side of the planet you know but also
just the way I look at myself you know
and that right there you know once we
start losing our own humanity within
ourselves I mean how can we expect to
have any humanity or any compassion for
anybody else you know we're so caught up
in our own Stardust and trying to figure
that out and and in my opinion kind of
losing our essence because we've kind of
given technology you know the label of
the the newest religion in the world
like we're also in sync with technology
that we we don't see the world for what
it truly is and that's a bunch of you
know primates running around trying to
figure it out you know and if we could
kind of peel back and get back to the
essence of humanity which is like I said
earlier compassion and being thoughtful
for one another and looking out for one
another without incentives we'll be back
on the right track damn that was so good
there's two really cool points there one
of them is that this the sense that we
have deep rooted within our within us
this wisdom of love and compassion and
we got here due to collaboration and
communication and to come back to that
at a deeper level is really important as
we move forward and then you explained
that we did get derailed with this
techno utopian mindset in many ways and
it's harder for us then to bond socially
give this love and this compassion to
each other in many ways it's easier to
potentially see a video of someone
around the world but it can also be more
difficult as we find ourselves behind
computer keyboards instead of looking at
each other in the eyes yeah and we have
to remember you know I I I try to I try
to toe I try to encourage myself and
others maybe not directly sometimes you
know indirectly but my message is always
we're already perfect the way that we
are we have to remember that I know that
technology offers these things that we
see as improvements you know when it
comes to the the human being itself and
you know we can send message
we can get information and we can get
oversaturated with information sometimes
and and and I know that all these things
seem to be these advantages these great
leaps and bounds that that that humans
themselves have have been able to invent
and to you know use but we must always
remember that the person who invented
all these things and the people who are
using all these things they're already
perfect the way that they are you know
they don't you don't need technology to
be a better human being you are already
you know the the the the pinnacle of it
all you you are it I mean that's the
message that I try to remind myself of
when I get caught up in technology and
and I feel like I'm kind of drifting
away from for myself you know we already
are perfect the way that we we're as
good as we're gonna get no amount of
technology is gonna make us any better
the only thing that's gonna make us
truly better and truly more worthy of
each other is when we start looking
inward and start thinking about how can
we help each other out and how can we
you know go back to just our own human
level and perfect that and always try to
make that better
you know swiping and scrolling that's
all that's all the distraction in my
opinion you know it's it's all a
distraction at the end of the day if
your goal is to find a better way to you
know to be a human being with one
another damn yeah okay you know there
are two quick things you the Nash
equilibrium here is really important
there's this potential of a point where
we can be focused on our own individual
selves and well-being while
simultaneously equilibrium balancing
that with the love for the collective
and the compassion for the collective so
what I do individually should never harm
them collective and so when we can
balance these two things out we can move
the baseline up for both the individual
and the collective simultaneously and
then I wanted to ask you about you know
this this idea that we're already you
know perfect how do you balance the idea
of being already perfect with the other
side of things which is I always want
room to grow right yeah well I would say
that you know we're perfect in the sense
that you know sometimes I'll take I'll
take I'll give you the example of God
you know people always say people always
relate God too
good but if you ask me you know God if
we're gonna talk about this Bing which
is God I mean God is good and evil all
the positive things that happen in the
world and all the negative things that
happen in the world that we you know
some some people will attribute it to to
darker energies the devil Lucifer or
whatever what look if God is Almighty
and all-powerful then he's he's the the
sunshine and the hurricane he's both
things yeah so that's what makes him God
though is that he can do is that he
lives in that dynamic he's part of both
positive and negative it's just part of
the package and that's what I'm asking a
few minutes the conscious state of
perfection yeah what's this [ __ ] see
whoa but that just goes to show you know
we've been we've been conditioned to
believe what God is just like I've been
stating that he's it's a he it's a he
it's a he I must I also grew up
believing that he is only positive you
know but the point I'm trying to make is
that we can call it all that is all that
is yeah and that and so so if you're
looking for God like you have to
remember that God is everything God is
the sunshine and the hurricane yeah if
you're looking for your humanity you
have to remember that that it's it's the
positive and the negative you know so
you have everything within you to up to
create positive change or negative
change but you have to be willing to
accept that you're both yeah you know
I'm thoughtful and self selfish yeah
yeah I know I'm happy and I'm also you
know suicidal sometimes I mean it's
pretty sure these things exist within
all of us you know and the sooner that
oh the sooner we start understanding our
own dynamic the sooner we'll start being
able to be compassionate towards the
human dynamic and and and but it takes
it takes some I think it really takes a
lot of inward searching yes you know and
that's something that technology
unfortunately has turned into a
distraction for us you know wiping and
scrolling instead of the inward search I
mean just a simple fact that people go
to the toilet to take a [ __ ] and they
can't go without their phone I mean
you're talking about you know exhausting
your bowels yeah yeah you know and you
got to be doing a benign something that
doesn't that doesn't cause you like
hemorrhoids and doesn't cause you pain
like there's yeah there's a there's an
actual
strategy to taking a poo so happy so
that you do it in the most
physiologically pleasing way right and I
hate to even bring up that example but
it's just that it's just that when I
find myself on the toilet scrolling I'm
thinking to myself what what am i doing
yeah yeah like why why why did I heal
I why did I feel it was necessary for me
to bring my phone into this moment you
know and it just goes to show how
attached we've become to technology and
I'm using the phone as you know the the
immediate example but it's such a huge
part of our life yeah yeah 150-day
exactly yeah exactly so instead of that
peace and quiet right when there's a
moment of oh I'm in line right now right
maybe I should look around at other
things
the beauty of earth other humans
understanding how the the process of
people in line this is part of an
economy yes does that work where does
the food get shipped in from its cedra
and you know we've we've lost the desire
to do that you know and but I don't
think that it's completely lost and this
is what I'm saying my message my message
to humanity is a hopeful one is an
optimistic one because I don't believe
that technology can truly extinguish our
humanity can truly extinguish the things
that we desire to want to have a
conversation to want to be listened to
want to be heard or to wanna you know to
the compassion that we have for a
creature or a person that's in front of
us that's suffering I don't think that
technology can truly extinguish that but
it is it is an enormous distractor
enormous and I don't I think that it's a
tragedy to live an entire lifetime where
you're so distracted that you didn't
even get to bask in the glory of what it
is that that you have already inside of
you that's already perfect if you ask me
if you're just willing to activate it I
love that that's so good that's so good
it's and we've we've been talking about
this so much on the show that it's a
tool just like the surgical instrument
can be used for repairing someone's body
there's nothing to stab someone
similarly with with technology we can be
using it to greater empathize with
people from around the world through
disseminating media to
billions of people or we can be using it
in the distractive way that doesn't
enable us to tune in word better
I wonder one more thing before we get
into more on the career is is you you
speak of this sort of all that is
includes the positive and the nakedness
it includes us constantly being at a
pinnacle of a civilization we're already
perfect in the way we are but now it's
just this formation over time of the
positive and the negative forming itself
over time how do how do you optimally
figure out how to keep yourself in a
positive AB and flow rather than being
overtaken sometimes by those
negativities well III think that one of
the biggest are two of the biggest fears
that we have is as humans that that is
out that keeps us you know trying to
continue continuously improve ourselves
or or or figure out a way where we can
make ourselves better you know through
technology for example I think that one
of the things that humans need to do
more often is we need to come to grips
with the fact that a nothing is going to
be many things in your life are going to
be imperfect many yes and be there is a
finality to all of this you know that
you are going to die that's imminent you
know and I really think that people are
always constantly trying to figure out a
way to be perfect and also constantly
trying to figure out a way to last
forever leave something behind that's
perfect that every one will ever see
because then that way I'll always be
alive not a minute you're gonna die and
you're gonna leave a lot of [ __ ] behind
that's gonna be imperfect and that's
just the way life that's that's part of
this exists even experience you know so
I tell myself in order to in order to
stay positive and in order to be in the
moment
I remind myself every single day you
know death is right around the corner
yeah but it's not a bad thing it's just
part of the deal yeah and also if I
don't have a perfect life or the things
that I've accomplished are not exactly
flawless that's also part of the deal
and once you once you come to grips with
these things you'd be surprised how the
type of drive that you find because you
start understanding that finality is
eminent and that that imperfection is
also eminent and and let me tell you
something man that's the pressure that
we subconsciously put on ourselves every
single day I really believe that and you
know that's why we want to have filters
on our pictures you know that's why we
have it that's why we have these ideas
of you know what if you were to able to
download somebody's brain and implement
it onto a machine so that they get their
conscious can last forever
look that's all that's all cool to think
about but what it really symbolizes what
it really indicates is our fear of
finality and our fear of imperfection
that these are the things that are
driving us on a day to day basis at a
very subconscious level in my opinion so
every single day I wake up in the
morning and I say you're not perfect
then you're gonna die and then that
right there is what I need the
motivation that I believe all of us
could you know could could use every now
and then just remember those two things
you know and that's what keeps me on my
toes and that's what keeps me trying to
always deliver a positive message or try
to stay positive because I know that you
know I've accepted I've accepted those
two truths you know I'm not perfect and
I'm gonna die it's all gonna it's all
gonna end and it might end up leave but
this is part of the human experience and
I'm okay with that and I go from there
and I remove that pressure for myself
subconsciously or at least I think I'm
doing that but that kind of gives me the
the energy and the drive that I need to
accomplish what I what I'm trying to
accomplish which is mainly at the end of
the day I just want to be in the moment
that's that's where I belong that's
where we belong that's where everything
is it's in the moment you know you can't
live in the past you can't live in the
future you got to you got to be in the
moment that's where it's all that the
other two are just illusions yeah you're
you're doing a you're doing a really
good job at explaining this sort of this
this simultaneous drive towards
understanding that we are perfect while
simultaneously understanding that we're
gonna die and we're gonna leave
unperfect mess as well and so to
maintain that balance throughout life is
so so cool and important and then also
there's now for thousands of years
humans have been practicing the thought
process of understanding death we have a
service that messages us every single
day five times a day that messages
and tells us it gives us a quote about
death right and we love using it because
it really causes us to look in the
mirror and reflect on oh we are we are
going to die and that we we we are
totally becoming more and more cool with
the thought process thinking about that
now how does one over time born in San
Leandro how does one find themselves
getting more into comedy more into radio
hosting how did you end up finding
yourself in that well I'll tell you the
first time first time I ever thought to
myself that wow I could really be on
stage and make people laugh and the
first time it actually happened and it
felt like you know like your first hit
of your of the first joint you ever
smoked through you're like whoa like you
know damn I never felt this way before
right seventh grade I'm doing a skit and
a school talent show my sister asks me
to help her write a skit because she
wants to be in the talent show I wasn't
even considering it and she goes yeah
can you help me write a skit you know
and make it funny so that you know we
can like you know we get little be a
funny skit that that will do in the
talent show I'm like alright I'm down
you know I hope y'all so I hope the
right ass kid knows a skit about I
played the role of a teacher I was in
seventh grade my sister was in fourth
grade and her and her two other friends
were wearing the skit as well I played
the role of a teacher a math teacher
trying to teach these three really dumb
kids how to do math but I was the dumb
one like I couldn't figure out you know
I was giving them two plus two is eight
and just all these ridiculous equation
math equations right so the joke was
that I was the I was the the ignorant
one in the classroom right and I did a
couple of I did I dropped a couple of
jokes I did some physical humor and I
just remember a man like in seventh
grade I'm like 12 years old at the time
12 or 13 something like that and I just
remember the entire cafeteria just
erupting and laughter and I even
remember what I was wearing that day I
was wearing a Atlanta Braves over at
lanta Braves hoody and and some cream
jeans I don't know why I had
cream-colored jeans but I guess that was
a style back then right and I just I
just remembered standing there and just
like listening to the crowd erupted and
laughter and that was something I never
felt before and that was a wave that
came over me that has never really ran
through me completely yet it's still
there
so when I realized that you know it's a
power there's some power behind making
people laugh you know III I took that
away in my heart and I said one day I'm
gonna return to this somehow some way
I'm gonna return to this and it always
stayed with me and I was always a ham
growing up as a kid but I never really
considered stand-up comedy until like my
early 20s when I was when I was rapping
because if you're from the Bay Area
every dude from the Bay Area had a rap
career at some point right and I was
rapping and then one day I was sitting
there you know kind of messing around on
the microphone talking [ __ ] to my
buddies who were recording the the
studio engineers who's really just the
guy who rolls the blunts and hits the
spacebar that's that's what the studio
engineer is back to back at the time and
he he he taps it into them into my
headphones and he goes hey man he goes
you're finding he goes you should uh you
should try to open you should try comedy
one day and it just hit me I remember
just standing there in the booth and I
just I realized I was like yeah you know
why haven't I I've never given it a try
it sounds like something that I I might
be able to get into and I went to open
mic at Tommy cheese in Pleasanton and
hit the ground running and never look
back and I realized I said wow yeah this
is what I felt in seventh grade yeah
yeah this is this is kind of the thing
that's been tugging out at my heart for
a while now that I'd never really you
know acknowledged but once I heard that
that laughter again I realized yeah this
was kind of in the cards for me but I
just had to deal them you know I just
have to play the cards that were dealt
and and see if I could come across that
feeling again and yeah that's where that
the comedy my first ever open mic which
is terrible totally you know I mean mojo
starts sinking threes right oh no no but
but when you hit a three you're 1 for 10
from the field on an NBA team you come
you that one three-pointer you like
sometimes my highlight reel coming back
through next exactly exactly so yeah man
it was just you know just something that
I had tucked away in my heart since I
was in a kid as a 7th grader and then it
just came out again in my early 20s when
I realized yeah I should give you
stand-up comedy or try I think I could
do that
and when I actually did it I was
terrible but a couple of laughs that
were that were out there yeah those were
the ones that that's what brought me
back and got me roll
all over again there's there's this
common thread between comedians is that
they adore their ability to to cause
dozens if not hundreds of people to
simultaneously crack up and start
laughing uncontrollably aesthetically
yeah and then that that if if you're
teach if you're passing along some sort
of a story an energy like that to a
large audience that does feel like you
said like this really powerful energy
and then so how does one find themselves
then writing you know you have to write
a plot write a punchline write a you
know have inflections in your voice have
pauses right to let thought yeah how do
you I mean I first of all I will
definitely say like you know every
single comic just like every single
author they have their own way of their
own style of coming up with jokes I mean
I know comics that never write anything
down they just kind of take a premise
and they kick it around a couple of
times until it's funny and then I know
people that are just like maniacally on
their laptop you know writing down every
single word putting every single
punctuation point making everything
perfect so there's definitely there's a
spectrum of how to write personally what
I like to do is I spend a lot of time
just writing quotes that I heard writing
down concepts notions a premise even if
it doesn't have a punch line I just like
to write these things down because the
way the way that I've the way I've
learned what I've learned about myself
is that I spend a lot of time thinking
about the things that I wrote when I'm
away from my notepad and I'm just kind
of living my life I spent a lot of time
thinking about those things and
throughout the day or throughout the
week or sometimes it'll take a month or
a couple of months that one line that
you wrote starts turning into an entire
bit and and when you take it on stage
you're you're helping it grow little by
little and then that's where the
taglines come in that's where the
inflictions and your voice come in
that's where the pauses the you know the
the pre-planned pauses that you know are
gonna help the joke that's where they
all start becoming a reality for me you
know but what but I definitely have a
a notebook it's just that I don't write
entire jokes on there I just write down
like I said things that come to mind
that I think are funny
yeah and they start growing legs from
there some sooner than others but that's
that's the way I like to get get I like
to lay the groundwork down is by writing
down my ideas I got to write my ideas
down because totally you know they'll be
gone they'll be gone they'll be gone
with the wind you know yeah yeah and
there's so many great comics out there
that have forgotten so many great bits
or the beginning of read bits because
you don't write them down and then you
always think that you're smart enough I
mean this is so good I'm definitely
gonna remember it because this is fun
this is great this is a great bit and
then two days later you're like what the
[ __ ] was I thinking I guess I say what I
said and then you just feel like an ass
cuz you're like my now if I would have
just wrote it down perhaps I could have
you know I could have made it into
something but I common ideas in comedy
in that sense are similar with ideas in
entrepreneurship sure well is that you
got a you got to grab them and write it
down and then follow up with it and keep
adding legs like she's right ads like
well we're selling something you know
where I'm selling somebody the idea yeah
I'm trying to be funny my goal is to
make you laugh but the truth is that I'm
trying to deliver a truth and make you
see the truth the way that I see it but
he's exactly yeah yeah because that then
at the end of the day that's what comedy
is comedy is just you know dancing it's
a dance that we do around the truth
that's why one of the most common lines
that you'll hear one of the most common
lines that you'll hear in the history of
you know life is it's funny because it's
true
it's funny because it's true or or
sometimes even the comics themselves it
cracks me up because we were I think so
many of us are actually searching out
the truth more than the humor in it
because sometimes we'll be standing in
the back of the club if you're standing
in the back of the club with the comics
a lot of comics when they hear a great
bit they won't laugh they'll say wow
that's funny
but the reason there's the reason
they're saying that is because they
recognize the truth and all of that you
know the laughter is just kind of like a
byproduct that comes with the truth
telling interesting but the comics will
say that's funny
without even laughing you know yeah and
that's how you know that that's a really
great bit you know because you're
pointing out the truth in all of it and
you're acknowledging the truth
this situation and that's really what
we're doing just like an entrepreneur
you're trying to sell an idea of so are
we you know we're trying to sell you're
trying to sell your truth and we're
trying to sell ours damn okay this is
cool I like the I like the the way of
framing this in a way that shows that
comedy has truth right there baked into
it and then that sometimes I think we
too frequently think that comedy has to
be hilarious yeah just exhausting of
laughter but comedy when somebody
because that that's fun yeah it's true
it's funny right and so that's a really
good point and I think that also ties a
lot into the current paradigm of culture
that we have where there's now so much
of so much feeling of being offended or
feeling of of some sort of an
malevolence like this is you're
attacking me or attacking other groups
or whatnot but there is something
interesting that we can learn from the
truth of all of these things so I guess
what would what would be your way of
delivering because there's different
troops we were talking about this before
Ian in terms of there's different ways
to propose a truth such as you can
propose a truth of the historian at
Davos that was that was poking at the
billionaires with their tax evasion
instead of their where they're trying to
speak on philanthropy right there's a
lot of funny things that we can poke at
there but then there's also trying to
poke fun at like different skin colors
or religions or world or preferences and
sex and sex right so there's like yeah
so how do you how do you figure out what
to how to dose truth and hope and comedy
into that well I think I think that one
of the problems that we have today in
terms of in terms of stand-up comedy is
that but the truth is that we are just
we're oversaturated with information so
what that creates is that creates a that
creates a culture where we've heard it
all we've seen it all you know it's it's
like what's next what's
it's somebody come up with something new
and that's not necessarily good for
comedy because here's the thing a guy in
California and a guy in and uh you know
Africa could think that the same exact
thing is very funny you know but we kind
of live in this world where like if I do
if I do it a bit and the guy in Africa
does a bit and somebody looks up on the
on my you know they go to YouTube and
they find a joke that I did and they're
like wait this guy in Africa did the
same joke well wait a minute this is odd
this are this is played out this is
hackish like how is this and I know
maybe Africa I don't know what the
African you know comedy scene is like
but what I'm trying to make though is
that two people in two totally different
parts of the world can come can merge
onto the same idea and the fact that
YouTube and Twitter and Instagram and
and things that we adore like that the
fact that they can offer us you know
both of these jokes it kind of makes it
seem like like oh this is played out you
know cuz this guy's telling this joke
and that guy's telling this joke but
this guy in California has no idea what
the guy in Africa is thinking and vice
versa these are just two guys trying to
tell their truth and they just both have
and because they're both truth seekers
there's a great chance that they could
come they could a stumble upon the same
idea but in two totally different parts
of the world you know but technology has
made it has taken us to a point now
where if I tell a joke now and then this
guy tells a similar joke later and on a
different part of the different part of
the country different part of the world
and makes it seem like like you put my
video up and then you put his video up
and it's like all they're doing the same
thing they're doing it's it's it's
played out it's hackish the truth is
that we just have too much access to one
another you know some of these ideas
some of these philosophies you know they
they they're they're born in different
ways and in different parts of the world
but everybody has to have the
opportunity to to speak their truth
everybody that's that's what that's what
creates a good comedy you know culture
is just giving everybody the the leeway
to just say whatever whatever it is that
they think is funny if you don't think
it's funny that's also valid yeah
that's also perfectly valid you know but
there are there are groups of people out
there that may think that that's funny
and perhaps he or she is just looking
for those groups that are gonna relate
to what it whatever
that they're trying to say you know and
so so when we talk about you know it's
like a free market it is it is a fit
that's exactly what he's kind of vote
with your laughter on where you want to
advance the comedic scene right now the
problem that I have you know the from
that I have when we talk about you know
PC culture the problem that I have is
that PC culture or whatever we're
calling it nowadays cuz I because I feel
like the label changes all the time you
know but but what I consider PC culture
it's actually I think it's it's not
helpful in terms of our ability to be
critical thinkers because if somebody
says something that offends you you know
you should be able that you should be
able to figure out a way to understand
that hey this is nothing personal this
is someone who was trying to be funny
and they failed at it and now I have no
business here whatsoever I can move on
with my life because the idea that
everything should that the idea that
everything that offends us should be
sent should be censored or or that we
should even make a big deal about it you
know that it should even bother us on a
personal level the whole like stop us in
our tracks and make us make us you know
complain or or be outraged that is just
promoting lack of critical thinking
interest when you promote that culture
you're promoting like you're basically
telling little kids little babies little
human beings who don't know any better
you're showing them that the way that
you deal with somebody's ignorant is by
allowing them to have real estate in
your mind and in your heart damn and
that is so unhealthy you know because
now what are you doing all you're doing
is creating little human beings that are
going to give everybody a key to the
real estate in their mind and in their
heart you're you're ruining that human
you should be teaching them the opposite
you should be telling them if you don't
agree with that person it doesn't mean
that you have to take it personal and it
doesn't mean that you have to harbor
that negativity that you think that
they're spewing it just means that you
and this person don't see eye to eye and
they can go their way and you can go
your way and that's how you create
critical thing is that's how you create
problem solvers yeah not just
complainers the other way is just we're
just creating a generation of
complainers that they don't even realize
that we're doing them a disservice so I
want to take this time to tell all the
future that all the kids maybe like 20
years old and younger because I got a
lot of cousins I wanted I'm really sorry
because we've been we're [ __ ] you
guys up we're telling you that it's okay
for you to give people the key to your
mind and to your heart
by allowing them to spew their
negativity that you consider harmful and
then you think that the the only way to
deal with it is by being you know
carrying that negativity with you and
being outraged and and being you know
upset truly truly hurt I'm sorry that we
did that to you because we should be
teaching you the opposite we should be
teaching you how to be stronger than the
negativity that that some people like to
spew or the ignorance that you see
around the world and teaching you how to
become a problem solver and not just a
complainer we owe them that you know
because that's that's what this
generation has done
unfortunately PC culture is at the
epicenter of all that and I don't even
like to call it PC culture because I I
mean I'll always talking about labels
and I really don't even want to label
that that's right I want to tell her
you're labeling it actually in the best
way I think right now by calling it lack
of critical thing lack of critical thing
yeah you know and I also really like the
way that you're saying that we're we're
giving people access to our heart energy
and our mind energy to our real estate
in ourselves where we're as we should be
able to help evolve society's ethics
away from these malevolent sort of
disgusting ways of violating each
other's well-being and moving towards a
more positive light but we can do that
through discourse and not necessarily
through censorship we can evolve ethics
in so many other ways and actually you
you know you talking about this in terms
of critical thinking is super important
for the future of as we go into the
exponential technology age you gotta
know how to how to be creative and
critically thinking about all different
types of issues and yeah we got to build
up the immune system this resilient most
definitely and that's what it is
that's what it's an immune system that
we've just allowed to just falter now
because the thing is that the
when you when you have when you've put
it into the hearts and minds of young
people or the the next generation or the
your kids whatever you want ever you
want to describe this new wave of people
that is you know gonna be controlling
the world and being the leaders of
tomorrow however you want to describe it
I mean we're here right now but what
we're teaching them is what I explained
you know that that your reaction should
always be outraged and harboring that
negativity and fighting with that other
person when in reality no parent wants
that for their kid know no parent would
ever just raise their kid and just allow
them to you know be so I don't even know
house to house to say this but allow
them to be so weak and and I don't mean
I don't mean weak as in you know if
you're out if you're offended by
something or if somebody says something
that hurts you that makes you weak I
don't mean I don't mean that way I mean
just on the on a reactionary level you
know where where it's like like for
example I'll give you this example you
know people always say people always say
that it should be okay for for boys and
girls to cry you know like why does it
why is it that when a little girl
scrapes your knee we say oh honey here
let me help you don't cry come here
daddy's here well but if your son
scrapes his knee it's like I get up
don't cry don't cry well I agree with
that you know I mean I do I do want boys
and girls to feel like it's okay to show
emotion that's a healthy human being but
I also want boys and girls to understand
that crying very rarely gets you the
results that you want boys and girls you
know so what I'm what what I'm getting
at is a nuance right there and see but I
want boys and girls to both understand
they're you know they're crying is
crying is not necessarily a sign of
weakness but if you're always crying you
will be weak yeah if that is your go-to
plan to always you know comfort always
complain and be hurt and to wait until
somebody comes to save you you will be
weak so I don't I would I don't want and
that's what you know bring it back to PC
culture I feel like where I feel like
we're conditioning kids to not know how
to handle critical thinking and critical
situations which is a complete
disservice to any society its right to
any culture you know think about how
agile we were in the last couple hundred
years thousand years of evolution that
we had to be taking in all of these
complex social stimuli yes about
different socio economics and different
of management's of resources and
different emotional states of our of our
tribe local tribe of people and
everything and then there was there
wasn't we had to we had to calculate all
of those variables and come out with
something that would address that moment
where you wouldn't beat the other person
over the head with a club or you won't
censor them or you wouldn't when they
when they scraped their knee you would
talk about how that feels but also how
we can bounce back and how we can move
forward and right this is this is very
crucial to not put the kids inside of
bubbles and not know how to how to how
to deal with adversity how to deal with
critical thought especially as we move
into the ex decade you have a very
interesting perspective on this and you
you hit some of the nuance and in good
detail what do you what do you um give
me your your your taste on what you
think we can do for adults and kids to
better deal with resilience and deal
with the nuance and the critical
thinking well I think that what one
thing that will be hell and look I'm not
a parent you know so I don't want I
don't want parents to think Ted you know
I know better than them I mean god only
knows like I can barely take care of a
plant let alive and I'm and I tried I
tried to like I go to home people in are
my little plants because I want to have
some some sort of you know life in my
shitty little apartment but but I always
die you know because I'm just I'm not
great I just keeping staying on top of
these things right so it's like I'm not
trying to tell parents how to raise
their kids but I do think but as a human
being who was raised by other human
beings that's what that's my in yeah
okay I have experience in that but we
need what is always needed for a healthy
Hume
being in my opinion is exposure you know
you have to you have to be out there you
have to see the the positive and the
negative things in life so that you know
what to anticipate you know so that you
kind of have a feeling for not
everything is going to be hunky-dory and
that and I just as a side note I want to
say that's where I give parents so much
credit because a parent is an artist you
know because here's the thing they they
want their kid to be grateful for what
they've given them because usually the
parents in the past they didn't have
these things so they want their kid to
be grateful for what they have but they
also want to make sure that their kid
never has to suffer like them you know
so so it's like well the only way they
could really be grateful is if they
suffer a little bit you know and in my
opinion like the kid has to know like
little human beings young human beings
have to know that negative things can
happen so you have to appreciate the
positive things so I really think that
you have to get a little bit of food
insecurity to understand how grateful
you are to have access to food most
definitely most definitely know so and I
feel like I feel like that you know that
we live in a time now especially in
America we live in a time now where
we're always trying to keep kids away
from harmful things you know even the
simple notion of of walking home from
school is completely you know outdated
now like there are some people that
would never dare to let their kid walk
around a neighborhood for half a mile
because what could happen what do you
think it happened I mean somebody good
you know kidnapped the kid or the kids
gonna get hurt and it's gonna be your
fault because you're a bad parent and
it's like what are you doing to this kid
to this little human being you're not
letting them experience the world that
you brought them into I mean honestly
though how dare we bring a kid and
create a life and then not expose that
life to the world that we're gonna leave
it behind it and I'm gonna say that you
have to let your kids walk to school at
the age of two or three or whatever but
I'm saying at some point you have to
realize you know we have to realize that
we need to expose ourselves to the
realities of life because that is the
only way that we're gonna be able to
survive and be competent in this world
for as long as we're here yeah not this
on
necessary like exposure to malevolence
that will cause trauma all right were
snob
course no no no but but but life is
malevolent some life is like you were
illustrating to us at the very beginning
this this responsibility that not only
the parents have but that society has
our social fabric has in making sure
that the minds that we mold into the
world have a full range of exposure to
the malevolence as well as the
benevolence so that they actually
realize what is what is good and what is
to be grateful for and what we should
steer clear away from as we continue to
evolve our ethics yes and this all goes
back to the you know the the dynamic
that we were talking about at the
beginning of the show you know where you
have you have good and bad you know God
is the sunshine and the hurricane you
know this is what this is what it is to
be human you know it's not just always
happy happy joy joy it's right there's a
lot of tears that are shed and there's a
lot of blood that's spilt sometimes and
there's a lot of the end and if we keep
if we try to hide all those scars so we
refer to as flaws and we try to hide
that we do the little human beings that
we're raising we do them a disservice
because now what do we do when they find
out on their own I know we're gonna be
there to help them through it but think
about what you allowed you allowed that
kid to be surprised by life's flaws and
how how as a parent as a mentor as a big
brother as whatever you may be in that
in that child's life how do you help
them through that trauma which is inside
of them you can tell them everything is
going to be okay but because you didn't
prepare them mentally and emotionally
for life's flaws and life's
imperfections and life's ugly side you
have no way of guiding them through that
trauma now they have to deal with that
on their own interesting it's it's as
though the the child gets exposed to a
malevolence and because they had no
training whatsoever with their immune
system that they are so shocked and
traumatized that they may not be able to
properly bounce back but right if there
was just the slight training adversity
training how to deal with
adversity how to deal with all different
types of walks of life and stimuli that
then it would be cake them to deal with
adversity or they would have some idea
of how to deal with it and they wouldn't
be completely in the dark you know
there's a big difference there's a big
difference from from you know walking in
the forest when it's completely pitch
black and walking in a forest when at
least you could see the moon yeah I know
that the moon is in the compass but when
you see the moon at least you feel like
okay I can hang on to something like I'm
still alive I'm not in the dark with
nowhere to go you know that might be
that might be a weird analogy but it's a
good one sunlight reflects off the moon
and it gives you a little bit of vision
and that moon is kind of like your your
built-up immune system a bit so that
when you face an adversity at night in
the forest you know how to tack it and
and and in other words it gives you hope
gives you at the very least it gives you
hope and when you're traumatized you an
extra edge exactly it gives you it gives
you something to latch on to and I think
that when when you're traumatized which
we all are at some point or like
something happens traumatic in our life
you know we have to to have that moon to
look at that gives you at least
something to follow at least you have an
idea of where you are you know but it's
totally different when you're walking
into completely in the complete dark
which I've done before and as a grown
man so hard and I had to walk half a
mile there's a long story but I had to
walk half a mile on the on the
countryside in Italy like two years ago
because I I completely mismanaged my
time and I missed my bus and they don't
do over out there so I have to walk on
the side of the freeway and it was
complete pitch-black at one moment for
like half a mile and that's a grown man
I'm sitting there having like a physical
I can feel myself getting tighter and
tighter to his foreign country the
foreign country you know because I had
to feel myself getting tighter and
tighter because I don't know where I'm
at I don't know what's in front of me I
don't know what's behind me I don't know
what's on the sides of me and so when I
came around the corner and I saw the
moon that at least gave me some hope I
was like [ __ ] I could see some something
you know there's something there so
bringing it back to the way that we do
it's art with our kids and the lack of
exposure that they that this current
generation is going through it really
perhaps maybe all generations you know I
don't want to make it seem like my
generation was are awesome
I'm sure that we've been you know
evolving for a long time now but but
when I when I look at this current
generation as a 36 year old man I say to
myself yeah we need more exposure
because we're already moving into a
world where technology is teaching us
that isolation is best and isolation is
fun and isolation is you know the the
pinnacle we're already moving into that
world with technology and these kids are
already growing up with the tools that
are gonna foster that idea so we have to
deliberately go out of our way to make
sure that kids are exposed to things now
more than ever because they're living in
a time where isolation is desirable
interesting so it's the weird we got a
we got a dose adults and kids with at
least a little bit incrementally to
start and we're dosing them with
adversities we're dosing them with
foreign cultures we're dosing them with
with traveling and with you know when
you take a photo maybe you take it like
right yeah rather you take it all silly
and stuff that doesn't it's not perfect
and that's okay yes and that's okay and
then and then you know you don't become
that person who has to take 50 selfies
because you want to see the perfect
picture of yourself you're not perfect
and that's okay that's beautiful we have
to start telling people that
imperfection and finality is beautiful
that should be desirable you know that
this life should be desirable because it
will end because you know it's gonna end
yeah and that's that should be what
gives us the motivation to want to go
out there and try all these different
things to be exposed to different things
too so you know the the III want sorrow
and I want joy you know this this is the
human this is the human experience yes
human beings discriminate the human
experience does not you know so when you
create a human being you can keep them
away from things or when we're out here
amongst ourselves you know even if
that's not my kid I want to always keep
in mind that this kid deserves from me
the truth because if I want to if I want
to help this kid who's gonna take my
place one day and in terms of you know
I'll be in the dirt and he'll still be
standing here shields will still be
standing I want to help them as much as
I
can by exposing them so what it is that
they're gonna be dealing with yeah as
long as they're here yeah this is this
has been very very wide-ranging and
interesting really this has been really
good yeah we're touching a lot of stuff
it's been a lot of fun it's a lot but
this is what I get into men I'm into I'm
into the human condition I'm passionate
about people and I'll tell you this man
I know compared to a lot of comics I
sound really corny saying that because
comics have this there's this idea where
you like you're supposed to be
anti-social where people are supposed to
kind of get on your nerves because
you're such an artist and you're so deep
into your head and you know and it's
like you know I I don't care what other
I don't care about other people life is
bad you're supposed to be this big cynic
look man I'm all those things IIIi know
life is is imperfect I know we're all
gonna die I know that people are shitty
many many times throughout life you're
gonna come across terrible people you
know but the I feel like I feel like the
the one thing that's always important to
remember though is that you know it's
the way that you like you treat people
the way that the way that you make
people feel like focus on being positive
for for others for other people's sake
because through that is where you're
gonna find your satisfaction I really
believe that you know I'm passionate
about people I like people
you know and and so I'm always
interested in what I can do to help
those that are around because you know
we can't save everybody you can't be
everything to everyone but you could be
something to someone yeah you know and
and if you if you can help one person
out like that then you've done a pretty
damn good job while you're here on this
earth you know but I really believe that
there's a lot of people don't agree with
that you know but that's just the way I
live my life because let me tell you
something if I don't believe the [ __ ]
that I was telling you right now I'd
probably go crazy because I'd go for so
far down into the cynical rabbit hole
that I'd probably go crazy and I'm gonna
see ma'am the one thing I don't want to
do in this lifetime is go crazy that's
that's it if I could just die sane or
what I believe to be sane I'll be okay
you know we're all a little bit we're
all a little bit we already are that's
the thing though we already are a little
bit so we're like constantly like a
garden that you just have the tent and -
you know if you don't tend to it it's
gonna go [ __ ] crazy in a while the
order you got to take care of those
plants gotta take care of this
so don't let those Home Depot players I
didn't think about that yeah I gotta go
home I gotta go the Home Depot and get
some more plans yeah I want to I want to
touch on this this this point of you
know you just you did some you did some
traveling to Italy some traveling to
France and traveling eradicate spigot
REE and traveling exposes us to
different walks of life and different
stimuli of how people live around the
world and in those scenarios you may
find that there are a majority of people
that maybe don't have access to a basic
need that you have access to so it
creates a deeper sense of humility and
gratitude all these things so tell us
about what that experience has been like
for you and why you recommend it so much
to other people I can tell you right now
just go into another country for me it
gave me something that gave me some
value towards something that I had never
really experienced and that is the value
of just shutting up and being quiet and
observing because the truth is that when
you're in a foreign country I mean first
thing that gets that you're stripped of
for the most part is your ability to
communicate because you nobody knows
what you're saying you don't know what
anybody else is saying and there's some
real value and just sitting there and
having to figure [ __ ] out because
otherwise you won't be able to get to
wherever it is that you got to get to or
get the food or get to the bathroom you
have to sit there and just observe you
know and just being quiet you know
because we live in the time where I mean
everybody wants to have everybody has a
platform everybody wants their voice to
be heard everybody wants to express
themselves and everybody wants to be
understood that's all you know I'm a
part of that too I'm on social media you
know I've fallen into that I'm part of
that fabric of our culture as well but
to be removed from that and not have the
ability to communicate with somebody the
way as easily as I'm communicating with
you right now
that really opens up your eyes and it
makes you realize like wow you know what
I I can figure [ __ ] out if I really need
it to I can really figure things out and
you don't realize that about yourself
when you're in your comfort zone it's
when you get out of your comfort zone
that you start realizing hey if I need
to figure something out I will and it
boosts your confidence in yourself in a
way that you had an experience before
because you never need it to you weren't
exposed to it
you imagine if you were so stuck in the
bubble that you could never expose
yourself to a foreign country because
you wouldn't know how to how to handle
yourself when you can't communicate
exactly that's really cool again you
tied that into facing an adversity and I
really like your perspective on that
because it slows you down it makes you
really think about how to how to how to
solve being in a foreign culture and
being exposed to new things too quick
two quick questions on the way out
first question wouldn't be simulation if
we didn't ask you are we in a simulation
who I believe we are we are we are in a
simulation because we live this life the
way that we see it in our minds and I
think that we're all living our own
simulation in that sense you know and
that's why the mind's eye and your
thoughts and your words are so powerful
more powerful than we give them credit
for because these are the things that
create the world that were literally
living in at least in your mind so
perhaps I can't see I can't get the
whole world to see the the I can't get
everyone to see the world the way that I
see it but I can live it the way that I
see it in my mind every single day
because I choose to be I choose that
simulation every day when I wake up in
the morning I choose the way that I'm
gonna the way that I'm gonna view the
world in the way that I'm gonna react to
it
so therefore I am in a simulation of my
own heart and my own mind and my own
desires and last question is what do you
think is the most beautiful thing in the
world
humility humility is the most beautiful
thing in the world I if I could tell you
this real quick I just I I've done a
really good job of telling this story
without crying the last couple of times
I've told this story but it just to give
you a heads up like it's one of those
things that puts me there but I really
do believe humility is the greatest
thing in the world and I learned that
when I was 12 years old you know it was
I was in a foreign country was in Mexico
I'm of Mexican descent so I go back to
Mexico with
family and I remember my dad who is
nothing like me in terms of personality
because we're you know I like to talk I
like to I'm more of an extrovert and
he's kind of the opposite of that which
is great because that was great to have
somebody so close to me that was nothing
like me so that I could I could see
other things through him right yeah so
that that was you know what sometimes
people just meet me and my dad they're
like damn you guys are related like
that's that's weird right but the reason
I say humility is I remember one day one
year I was 12 years old we went to
Mexico and my dad's walking we're
walking around the town my dad's town
and cobblestone roads you know a lot of
lot of people out there in the streets
begging things that a twelve-year-old
American boy is not really accustomed to
you know because our poverty here is
nothing compared to third-world poverty
I can say that pretty confidently you
know you you go to some parts of the
third world and its hellish less than
two bucks a day yeah exactly yeah
I'm in the conditions too you know two
bucks you can only stretch it so far
well anyways we're walking around town
and we see my dad sees somebody begging
and are the somebody somebody who was
begging sees my dad and he approaches my
dad and I'm already upset I'm 12 years
old I want to go home I want a Big Mac
you know I want I want to go and play
Nintendo like I want to go live my life
you know my life of luxury my and my dad
is approached by this man who asked for
who's asking for money and I'm about 15
feet away ahead of them because I want
to get home already and get the hell out
of there and I look at my dad my dad
says something tomorrow I don't know
what he said to him but he looked down
at his feet and the man had no shoes and
I'll never forgive my dad he had black
feelers on black high-top Feliz and he
took off his own shoes he fixed them you
know kind of cleaned them off put him in
front of the guy and he said here I'm
gonna take these and the guy took the
shoes put him on he gives my dad this
crazy hug crazy like Chi like passion I
mean like the guy was weeping and my dad
walks home like another mile and a half
just in his socks on these old
cobblestone
Rhodes you know and I'm 15 feet away cuz
I'm 12 13 years old and I'm reluctant to
accept the fact that I'm wrong in this
situation that I'm acting like a total
[ __ ] I'm reluctant to accept it but I
can't because my own humanity won't
allow me to just you know be okay with
the fact that I I just witnessed
something so beautiful and and yet I'm
still I'm still not engaged you know my
own humanity made me tear up in that
moment and I'm walking home like living
this weird dynamic in that moment
because I I'm a 12 13 year old kid who's
reluctant to be in the third world and I
want to go home and this isn't that but
I also can't help but feel that the
humanity and what I just witnessed you
know it was a weird it was a weird it
was it was a conflict and emotions in
the moment but what I would I would I
always take from that is that I couldn't
have witnessed something more beautiful
than the humanity of my own dad who
decided to take off his own shoes and
give it to a beggar someone who didn't
have any any anything on their feet any
shoes at all and every since that moment
it made me realize that humility
humility is is is the key to so many
things you know in in this lifetime so
when people ask me what the most
beautiful thing is I always say it's to
be able to humble yourself because when
you humble yourself you can begin to
make things better and there's nothing
more beautiful in this world than
somebody who's actively trying to leave
this place better than the way you found
it yeah yeah
so humility would would definitely rank
at the top of the list in terms of
what's the most beautiful thing in this
world in my opinion to him what a
powerful story with your father it was
crazy never never forget that and like I
said like I've had I've done better
lately and telling that story without
crying but I can't you know even 22
years later you know when I think about
that I I have to hold back the tears
because it was just a powerful lesson in
my life you know so huge influence that
a parent can deliver to their child by
I'm making an act of humility and
gratitude and compassion
yes humanity
and look at how much it affected you
still today and even even to this day
when I talk about you know III really
think that that moment is directly
connected to my passion for people to my
up to my desire to want to help humanity
out even if it's on a small scale even
if it's helping a homeless person out in
the moment I mean I would love to do it
on a grand scale but you know how you
think global and you act local and
that's how you start that's right you
know so yeah I really believe that all
these things are tied in to that moment
so when somebody asked me what I think
the most beautiful thing is I think of
that moment and I can't help but but
offer up my answer of humility being the
most beautiful thing in this world is
such a pleasure
likewise knows a blast but this is super
fun yeah anytime you need a pinch-hitter
let me know oh yeah oh yeah this was
super fun there's super wide-ranging
conversation and yeah and I'm and I'm
happy to have have seen your mental
lattice to have started unpacking it
because like I really like it there's a
great thing you guys are doing setting
up this platform because there's there's
people like me that love this type of
stuff and so I'm just glad that you have
the platform going and please keep it
keep it going
don't wouldn't want to see more of this
type of stuff we will this is what we
need now so we need now maybe these
longer form nuanced Riven conversations
and look at how many cool wisdoms you
pulled out you know there were a bunch
of good ones well you know hey iron
sharpens iron man iron also I'm out here
we're bouncing ideas off each other
we're sharing yeah you know we people
got to share more than more than then
we're like we're used to doing now we
have to be willing to share with one
another because iron sharpens iron yeah
yep we love you all thank you so much
everyone for tuning in we would love to
hear your thoughts in the comments below
let us know your thoughts also check out
Rudy's links he's got tons of events
coming up he's got tons of videos as
well go and check those out also guys
support local artists local comics
support local entrepreneurs think
globally act locally do it do it this is
the way we can sustain and grow support
us as well all the links are below
everyone much love we love you so much
go and build the future everyone
manifest that destiny into the world
shout out to around Vegas producer and
director
all right peace out everyone
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]